congratulations on the film guys I fit
was amazing so Sunday you're a trapeze
artist and Zak you're kind of running
the show a little bit so but if you were
actually at the circus what would you
want your special talent to be oh well
now that I've worked so hard to learn
the trapeze I'm gonna go with trapeze
yeah I mean I got like a little taste of
the trapeze but I mean that requires a
lot of balance and our body strength
it's it's pretty pretty cool to watch
yeah I mean unless you've been in the
circus recently how much did he do yeah
I walked into her so I know for a fact
she was all she did all her trapeze like
real flipping and catching trapeze I saw
that like on it's being executed on day
one for my rehearsals yeah first time I
walked in it was really her doing it I
couldn't believe it I thought it was a
professional something that it was her
and it's very a list cursed what was it
like working with Hugh Jackman and
Michelle Williams a list there was
awesome I mean Hugh Jackman's like my
hero
so yeah yeah I really look up to that
guy and still do so cool so nice
hard-working determined like all the
great positive things you could possibly
say just go ahead and say it about you
and everybody will back it up because
he's just everyone you mean it's like
isn't even nicest guy he's like yeah
he's like that's exactly what you get if
anyone has ever met who says the nicest
things about him so naturally I was like
not in a good mood and just like a
wonderful human no he confessed he
confessed me he has had one before yeah
a long time ago
he remembered he in a bad day he never
shows it because after knowing him then
I went to go see Logan after and I was
like he was like you know he's cussing
and he's you know mad I'm like it's like
so like you'd like so different see you
couldn't be that as good as he was and
Logan without having at least water - it
was really while we were filming Logan
came out so we were saying you know
dancing and so excited to be a word and
I love the side track so much what are
your favorite songs they're all really
unique and catchy and different and so I
I don't know that it depends yeah it
really depends daily or where you're at
in the movie but all the songs are they
serve they serve a really unique purpose
and you connect with each moment
differently so I mean our numbers catchy
you can hear it on the radio like it's
it's a classic love ballad which I
really enjoy
but then I mean Rebecca Ferguson sings
the song yeah and then it's so powerful
yeah
exactly I'll see you leave that one
exactly so I don't know yeah and then
coming home I don't know they're all
good seriously you'll know what we mean
when you see it yeah yeah it was written
a lot of the songs were written by the
same writers is the la-la-land sign
track and there's been a little bit of
Oscars buzz already what do you make of
that there has been yeah from whom from
yeah
the Oscar press that's that's nice to
hear that's really that's awesome